في الساعه الثانيه والنصف صباحا بتوقيت
موسكو بدا هجوم المسيرات التي تتهم روسيا
غريمتها اوكرانيا بالوقوف وراءه 16 دقيقه
تفصل المسيره الاولى التي انفجرت فوق قصر
مجلس الشيوخ وتسببت بحريق وبين الثانيه
التي تحطمت على اراضي قصر الكريملين تقول
موسكو
نفت الاتهام واعتبرته العوبه روسيه لحشد
مزيد من الدعم للرئيس الروسي في ظل غياب
النصر العسكريه تصريحات تماشت مع موقف
واشنطن التي اعتبرت ان الثقه مفقوده في اي
تصريح او اتهام يخرج من الكريم اما الامم
المتحده فدعت موسكو وكافلي وقف اي تصريحات
تؤدي للتصعيد مستمرون معكم في تغطيتنا
لتطورات الاحداث في موسكو اهلا بكم
مقر الرئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم
بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت
موسكو الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي
تحمي مركز المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل
المدن التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على
كريملين خاص بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي
تابعنا لقطات له هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين
الذي يطل على الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره
تابعه لرئاسه الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر
عن القصر الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار
وكما اعلنت موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير
الطائرتين المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات
الالكترونيه في الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار
ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غرب الكرملين
[موسيقى]
اكد مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل
كان لا علاقه لاوكرانيا بالهجوم الذي
استهدف الكريم بطائرات مسيره موضحا ان
مهاجمه الكريم ليست هدفا لاوكرانيا
اكرر هذه الرساله واعتقد انها ستكون على
الاقل مفهومه للجميع نحن لا نهاجم بوتين
او موسكو نحن نقاتل على اراضينا نحن ندافع
عن قرانا ومدننا ليست لدينا اسلحه كافيه
لهذا السبب لا نستخدمها في اي مكان لم
نهاجم بوتين لكننا نترك المجال للمحكمه
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ديمتريديف ان الخيار امام روسيا الان بعد
الهجوم على الكرملين سوى قتل الرئيس
الاوكراني زلنسكي واعضاء حكومته واضاف انه
لا حاجه لبقاء الرئيس الاوكراني على قيد
الحياه لوقع على استسلام اوكرانيا فدائما
هناك بديل على حد وصفه
مجلس الدومه الروسي دعا لتوجيه ردا قاسم
على محاوله استهداف الكريم التي كانت تهدف
الاغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين حيث قام
باطلاق نداء لتدمير نظام كاف بعد الهجوم
على الكرملين وقال مجلس الدمى الروسي بان
الهجوم على سبب لاطلاق حرب حقيقيه في
اوكرانيا وبان الوقت حان لاطلاق هجوم
صاروخي على مقر اقامه الرئيس الاوكراني
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
فقال ان واشنطن لا يمكنها التحقق من صحه
تقارير استهداف بوتين في الكريملين
بمسيارات واضاف بلينكن ان واشنطن تنظر
بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن الكرملين
مؤكده انها لا تعرف ما الذي حدث هناك كما
قال ان قرارات اوكرانيا لكيفيه الدفاع عن
نفسها تعود لها وان واشنطن واثقه بانها
ستنجح في استعاده ما تبقى من اراضيها
لقد اطلعت على التقارير ولا يمكنني التحقق
من صحتها باي شكل من الاشكال فنحن ببساطه
لا نعرف اود ان اخذ اي شيء يخرج من
الكرملين بعين الريبه لذا دعنا نرى سنرى
ما هي الحقائق من الصعب حقا التعليق او
التكهن بهذه الامور دون معرفه الحقائق
اظهر مقطع فيديو الذي نشره الكريم ما يرجح
انهما رجلا امنا كان يصعدان على قبه
المبنى قبل استهداف المسير بثوان ولم يتضح
ما اذا كان رجلان في مهمه امنيه لاعتراض
او التشويش على المسيرتين غير ان الكرملين
اكد عدم وقوع اي ضحايا او اضرار ماديه
لمتابعه ما يجري في موسكو تنضم الينا الان
مراسلات العربيه اهلا بك معنا الاجواء
لديك اليوم
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل اليوم كانت الكرملين
او كان الكرملين قد تحدث عن استهداف غير
مسبق لقلب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ساحه
الكرملين ومقر الرئيس الروسي طبعا
ليله يوم امس والتي تم طبعا استهدافها من
قبل منظمه الدفاع تابعه للساحه الحمراء
وبالتالي تم تدميرها لم يكن هناك اضرار
وكما تحدث بيسكوف ان هذا
هذا الاستهداف هو من الجانب الاوكراني كان
هو وصفه بالعمل الارهابي الذي كان يستهدف
الرئيس الروسي لاديمير بوتين بشخصه هو ان
موسكو طبعا كما قال ستقوم بالرد بالوقت
الذي تختاره وبالطريقه التي تختارها على
هذا الهجوم هو من نوعه هو الذي طبعا اخترق
اجواء موسكو لاول مره واخترق قلب العاصمه
كما تحدثت وهو الكرملين وهو هذا التوقيت
اولا ياتي قبيل احتفالات عيد النصر من
جانب ومن جانب اخر هو هذه الهجمات كنا
نشهدها خلال الفتره الاخيره على الاراضي
الروسيه باستخدام مسيارات سواء كانت
استهدفت المناطق الحدوديه لروسيا اليوم
كان هناك ايضا اسقاط ليس فقط في سماء فوق
تم اسقاط مسيرات ايضا في ضواحي موسكو كما
تحدثت وسائل الاعلام روسيه بالاضافه منذ
قليل كان هناك حديث لوسائل الاعلام روسيه
عن اسقاط ايضا او تحليق مسيره في في اجواء
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لذلك هناك تكثيف
كبير
للمسيرات كما تقول موسكو هذه المسيرات هي
تاتي من الجانب الاوكراني وتستهدف الاراضي
الروسيه
كل هذه التطورات هل من اجراءات غير
اعتياديه اصبحت او اصبحتم تشاهدونها منذ
استهداف الكرملين حتى الان
هو تكثيف امني شديد في العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو كان قد بالاساس مع بدء التحضيرات
للاحتفالات العيد النصر الذي ستجده
العاصمه خلال الفتره القادمه ولكن اليوم
كنا قد شهدنا من خلال مرونه بشوارع
العاصمه روسيا موسكو ان هناك تكثيف كبير
للحضور الامن والشرطه في كافه انحاء
العاصمه الروسيه والتي تقترب طبعا من
الكرملين هناك تكثيف كبير للشرطه لتواجد
الشرطه بالتالي هناك طبعا استعداد امني
كبير تحسبا لوجود مخاطر جديده وتحسبا
لحدوث حوادث جديده من هذا النوع طبعا كان
هناك حديث الكريمينال منذ ايام كان هناك
تخوف طبعا وتوقع لان يكون هناك حوادث
قبيله بدء احتفالات عيد النصر تحدث بنفسه
قال ان هناك تخوف من ان يكون هناك طبعا
استهداف
للاحتفالات اعيد النصر وبالتالي روسيا او
موسكو تقوم بتعزيز
على خلفيه هذه الاحتفالات طبعا كما تعلمين
ميسون الاحتفالات هي ستقوم ستكون الاسبوع
المقبل في التاسع من مايو وكما قال
الكرملين انه لن يكون هناك اي تغيير في
خطط هذه الاحتفالات على خلفيه هذا الحادث
وان الرئيس الروسي
سيكون حاضرا خلال هذه الاحتفالات ولن يكون
هناك اي تاثير على هذه الاحتفالات بعد هذا
الحادث الذي استهدف الرئيس الروسي بنفسه
ميسون بالنسبه للشارع الروسي كيف يتعامل
مع هذا الاستهداف
حقيقه ميسون اولا هذا الاستهداف ياتي بوقت
كما ذكرت لك هو وقت الاحتفالات بعيد النصر
والذي هذا الاحتفال هو
يشكل اهميه كبيره لكل مواطن روسي بيئه
بالاخص ما يخص الحرب العالميه او الحرب
الوطنيه العظمى التي قضت فيها روسيا على
النازيه وهذا هو السبب التي بدات به موسكو
كما تقول العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي ردود الفعل هنا كانت متباينه بين
تخوف وترقب لرده فعل روسيا على هذا الحادث
من حيث طبعا رده الفعل بالقصف او
رده الفعل العسكريه على اوكرانيا ومن هناك
ايضا كان تخوف من المشاركه بهذه
الاحتفالات بسبب ان يكون هناك استهدافات
او تخوف من ان يكون هناك استهداف امني
لهذه الاحتفالات هل من الممكن ان يكون
هناك تخوف من الحضور
بالتاكيد ميسون هناك تخوف ابن الحضور لان
روسيا كانت قد الغى لغت العديد من
الاحتفالات في المدن التي هي تقع على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا او الحدوديه او التي
يتم استهدافها بشكل مستمر تم الغاء
الاحتفالات بعيد النصر هناك ولكن الاحتفال
في العاصمه الروسيه هو لا يزال قائم
تم الغائها بسبب تخوف ان يكون هناك حوادث
امنيه وبالتالي بالطبع اكيد هناك تخوف من
ان يكون حوادث خلال احتفالات عيد النصر
على الرغم من التجديدات الامنيه وبالتالي
ياتي هذا الحادث ليزيد الخوف لدى
المواطنين ان الروس في حال طبعا المشاركه
او الخروج للمشاركه بهذه الاحتفالات يوم
التاسع من الشهر الجاري اشكرك حتى الان
دائما سنكون معك في نشرتنا اللاحقه
لتطلعين على الاجواء والاوضاع او اي تطور
يحصل في موسكو شكرا لك حتى الان اما الان
ينضم الى من واشنطن عبر زوم
نائب المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه سيدتك اهلا بكم
معنا لماذا الثقه مفقوده من قبل الولايات
المتحده باي تصريح خارج من الكرملين
ان هذا لا ياتي من قبيل المفاجاه
ومن المعتد بان الولايات المتحده تبقى
ملتزمه في فعل ما بوسعها لضمان الحصول على
نتائج ايجابيه عندما يكون هناك احترام
لمساله الهدن وقف اطلاق النار والتحول الى
حكومه مدنيه
بالنسبه لما حدث اليوم في الكرملين الكريم
وهي حليف لكم وانتم تمولوها
لحربها مع روسيا هل سيتاثر ذلك هل ستزيدون
مثلا من هذه المساعدات من الحمايه خاصه
للرئيس بما انه سيد مدفيد قال بانه يعني
يجب قتل الرئيس واعضاء حكومته
يتعلق بما حدث ليله الامس
فاحيلك الى الحكومه الاوكرانيه للرد على
هذا الموضوع لم يتم التحقق من الاتهامات
التي واجهتها روسيا وكما ذكر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي لابد ان ننظر الى هذه
التصاريح الروسيه بقدر كبير من الشيك
فسياسه الولايات المتحده لطالما كانت
ترتكز على الدعم اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
مناطقها في وجه الغزو الروسي الغاشم واذكر
المشاهدين هنا ان روسيا هي التي تعد
الدوله الغاشمه التي بدات بالعمليات
الهجوميه الدمويه ضد المدنيين والبنى
التحتيه والسعه لاخافه الشعب الاوكراني من
خلال حرمانه للوصول الى الكهرباء
والخدمات الاخرى هذه الاجراءات
تعد ذات طابعا تستحق معه الادانه
روسيا تقول بانه
في بعض الاوقات بانه السيد ذا لينسكي ليس
هو صاحب القرار وهناك ايضا من يريد ان
يورط الغرب الدول الاوروبيه في همس الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كيف تردون على
ذلك
هذه اتهامات
سخيفه ولا اساس لها من الصحه لا يمكن لاي
دوله ان تقوم بغزو اوكرانيا والسيطره على
سيادتها وروسيا هي التي تسعى لتحقيق هذا
المشروع من اجل اباده الاوكرانيين بصوره
كامله الولايات المتحده وحلفائنا في الغرب
كانوا واضحين منذ البدايه باننا لن نن
الخريطه باي
اجراءات تتعلق باوكرانيا الا بالتنسيق مع
اوكرانيا والامر متروكي للشعب الاوكراني
ليقرر مصير هذا الصراع والشعب الاوكراني
من خلال قادته المنتخبون الديمقراطيين لهم
خيار الدفاع في مواجهه الغزو الروسي طب
سيدتك الولايات المتحده تقول بانها حتى
الان لا تعرف ما حصل في
الكريب ولكن لنكن واقعيين الولايات
المتحده وقوتها وخاصه الاستخباراتيه هل من
الممكن لا تعرف من يقف وراء ما حصل اليوم
في الكرملين
لا نقول الا ان هذه التقارير لم يتم
التحقق منها واي تصاريح تصدر من روسيا يجب
ان تاخذ بقدر من الشك والريبه وما زلنا
نركز على مساله دعمنا لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن
نفسها
من استمراري العمليات الهجوميه الروسيه
الى الى التصاريح التي صدرت عن الحكومه
الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بتلك الاتهامات
والامر متروك لهم للحديث عن نفسهم وليس
نحن ولكن سيدتك يعني انتم غير معنيين بان
تعرفوا ما حصل بالتحقيق حول ما حصل حتى لا
تكون هذه ذريعه مثلا لاستهداف اكبر لاعلان
حرب مفتوحه اكبر على اوكرانيا وبالتالي
انتم حليف مقرب من اوكرانيا ومن الممكن ان
تطال ايضا بعض الدول الاوروبيه
مره اخرى انت تسالين متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
احيلك بالسؤال للقوات العسكريه للرد على
هذا السؤال ونحن انا لا اسال سيدتك لا
اسال عن القوه العسكريه انا اسال انتم
كالولايات المتحده غير معنيين بمعرفه ما
حصل
هل انتم كالولايات المتحده الامريكيه غير
معنيين بما حصل سيدتك
هذه الحادثه حي حادثه لم يتم التحقق منها
واحيلك بالامر لسلطات الاوكرانيه للتحدث
عن عمليتها الخاصه
الولايات المتحده بكل تاكيد تعمل بالتنسيق
السيخ مع حلفائنا في النيتو للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا وسلامه اراضيها لكن اوكرانيا لها
القرار في كيفيه المضيء في هذه الحرب الا
تتخوفون من ان تصبح هذه الحرب مفتوحه
وبالتالي لطالما روسيا كانت تهدد بسلاح
نووي
هذه الحرب قد تنتهي يوم الغد اذا ما
التزمت روسيا بالقواعد الدوليه وسحبت كافه
قواتها التي نشرتها واحتلت بصوره غير
قانونيه مناطق الشاسعه في اوكرانيا هذه هي
طريقه انهاء الحرب لكن
روسيا للاسف قررت بان تمضي
بتلك الحرب الهمجيه والمغامره التي لا
جدوى منها في اوكرانيا ونجم عنها ارتكاب
جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد الانسان من قبل
القوات الروسيه لذا فان الخيار الوحيد
لضمان
وقت في هذه الاعمال العنفيه المقيته هي
تتمثل من خلال التزامي روسيا بميثاق الامم
المتحده وسحب قواتها هذه هي الطريقه
الوحيده التي يمكننا ان ننظر من خلالها
للمستقبل للتوصل الى نتائج سلميه روسيا
تعتبر ما حصل اليوم هو محاوله اغتيال
لرئيسها ومحاوله اغتيار رئيس دوله في حرب
في صراع يهدد السلام العالمي الولايات
المتحده كيف تنظر الى هذا الامر الا تتخوف
من ذلك
لن اخذ اي تصاريح تطلقها روسيا على
انها صحيحه ولابد من التحقق من هذه
الادعاءات التي تطلقها روسيا ما تقوم به
روسيا من خلال هذه التصاريح هو محاوله يرر
رمادي في العيون وتبديد الانتباه بان
روسيا قد تقوم بالتصعيد في هذا الصرع مره
اخرى انها روسيا هي التي اظهرت بان الدوله
الغاشيه في اوكرانيا من خلال شن عملياتها
التي انطلقت في الفبراير من العام الماضي
وما تزال مستمر في شن عمليات هجوميه ضد
المواطنين الاوكرانيين لدى اي تصريح من
قبل الروس فقد يكون هو لتبديد الانتباه عن
هذا عن ما يدور بصوره حقيقيه وهو امر خال
وعار عن الصحه اشكرك من واشنطن كنت معي
عبر زوم نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه
من كافه ينضم الينا الان مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل حذيفه كيف يبدو الوضع الان في
كافه بعد هذا التصعيد وهل من تخوف هل من
اجراءات على الارض
شاهدتوها او لاحظت بان هناك اي تغيير خاصه
كاجراءات امنيه على الارض
مساء الخير ميسون الوضع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف طبيعي جدا لم يتغير شيء
كان هنالك حاله انذار جوي مرتين في بعض
طبعا الاعلان عن مسؤوليه تكييف من قبل
موسكو حول هذه الضربه التي طالت
تم اطلاق 26 طائره من طراز شاهد 136 و131
نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه استطاعت قوات
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه ان تسقط 21 منها
ايضا تم تنفيذ ما مجموعه 21 ضربه جويه
ايضا كذلك تم تنفيذ 25 هجوما دراجات
الصواريخ هذا في جميع انحاء نتحدث ايضا عن
الجبهات كذلك هذه الضربات نفذت في مناطق
في اغلبها قريبه من الجبهات نحو العاصمه
كيف لم تطال العاصمه اي ضربه المواطنين
بشكل هادئ جدا استقبلوا كل هذه الانباء في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وكذلك في الاعلام
سواء كان المحلي او العالم يتحدث الى بعض
المواطنين سالتهم ان كان هذا الام يغير
شيء بالنسبه لخططهم في الفتره القادمه
خاصه اننا مقبلون على التاسع من مايو
وتعلمين انه عيد النصر وهنالك توقعات
تحدثت عنها السلطات الاوكرانيه حتى من قبل
عن انه يمكن ان يكون هنالك اي اجراءات او
تنفيذ ضربات استفزازيه من قبل الاتحاد
الروسي طبعا تعلمين ان الاتحاد الروسي
يحمل المسؤوليه لكيف كان هنالك رد من اكثر
من مسؤول من مسؤوليكييف ابتداء من الرئيس
فلاديمير الذي صرح في المؤتمر الصحفي في
فنلندا يعني عندما سئل حول ضربه الكريملين
وقال اننا لا نستهدف موسكو اننا لا نستهدف
اننا لا نستهدف بوتين ونحن فقط ندافع عن
اراضينا كذلك ميخائيل بوزلاك مستشار
الرئيس زيلينسكي اعتبر ان هذه حمله دعائيه
مسبقه لامر يدبر الان
نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه ان هنالك ستكون
هجمات استفزازيه واسعه النطاق على ان هذا
الامر دبر وكان هنالك تمهيد له القبض على
عدد كبير من ما سمتهم موسكو بالمخربين في
شبه جزيره القرم كانت هذه مقدمه الامر
والان قال اننا نشاهد يعني
الجزء الثاني من هذه التمثيليه او
المسرحيه حول ضربه الكريملين ايضا
استغربوا من انه هل موسكو غير قادره على
صدرون صغير جدا حتى وصوله الى الكريم هذه
كما يقولون انها تمثيليه من قبل كذلك قوات
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه قالت ان الان يتم
تزوير فكره ان هنالك تصعيد من قبل كيف نحو
موسكو وهذا لينقل هذه الحرب الى مرحله
جديده والاستفزازات واسعه قد تكون من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي كذلك صرح الناطق الرسمي
باسم الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي السيد
نيكيفر وقال اننا النكيب غير مسؤوله تماما
عن هذه الضربه هذه تصريحات من قبل
الجهات الرسميه في كيف كذلك يعني قلت لك
ان تحدثت الى المواطنين وسالتهم انه هذا
الامر
سيغير شيء في خططهم في الفتره القادمه
قالوا انهم سيبقون هنا يعني هذا راي من
تحدثت اليهم عدد قليل من الناس قالوا انهم
لا تتغير خططهم ولكنهم سيضعون في اعتبارهم
اي انذا حاله انذار جوي سيذهبون الى
الملاجئ لن يخرجوا من كيف كما قالوا ولكن
في حاله حدوث تصعيد سوف يقومون بالخروج
سوف يقومون بعمليه تجهيز بسيطه يعني سوف
يعبون على سبيل المثال السيارات بالوقود
لتكون جاهزه في حاله حدث اي شيء او هجوم
واسع نحو العاصمه ايضا بعض الطعام والمياه
للطريق اذا ما كان هنالك يعني حوجه لعمليه
اجلاء سريعه وخروج من
المقرر الرئيسيه كرئاسه جمهوريه ايضا
المركز الحكومه
رئاسه الاركان هل شاهدتم اي اجراءات
زادت خلال الساعات الماضيه بعد كل هذه
التصريحات من قبل كياف بانه يجب ان يتم
استهداف مقر الرئاسه يجب قتل سيلينسكي
واعضاء حكومته
نعم ميسون انا اقف الان تماما في وسط
مراكز صنع القرار يعني هذه المنطقه التي
اقف فيها من حولي هي مراكز صنع القرار
مكتب الرئيس فلاديميرزقي لم يتغير شيء
الحراسه كما كانت حتى الارتكازات العسكريه
للجيش كما هي تماما وهذه الاجراءات هي لم
تقل ولم تزيد منذ اليوم الاول في الحرب هي
هي هنالك ارتكازات هنالك تفتيش للدخول
لهذا المربع السكني الواسع انا لا اتحدث
فقط مكتب الرئيس نفسه او الطرق التي تحيط
به ولكن حتى المنطقه السكنيه من في محيط
مكتب الرئيس هي مغلقه بالكامل لا يمكن
للسيارات ان تدخل اليها فقط المواطنين
الذين يسكنون لديهم تصاريح يتم استخراجها
من جهاز الامن والمخابرات بعد ان يثبتوا
انهم يسكنون في هذه المنطقه يدخلون على
ارجلهم يتم تفتيش يعني صغير لبعض الاشياء
التي يحملونها اذا كانت وحتى السيارات
هنالك تصريح لسيارات المواطنين الذين
يسكنون المنطقه هنالك انتشار واسع جدا
للجيش ولي جهاز الامن والمخابرات الوطني
والاجهزه وحرس الرئيس في هذه المنطقه لذلك
لم يتغير شيء ايضا يعني في هذه الجهه ايضا
يوجد وزاره الداخليه وعدد من الوزارات
وحتى جهاز الامن والمخابرات الوطنيه ليس
ببعيد من هذه المنطقه الاجراءات لم تتغير
ودون ذلك لم نلاحظ اي تغيير لا يوجد اي
يعني انتشار واسع
للاجهزه الامنيه كما قلت لك الامر يسير
بهدوء حتى انني كنت في محطه القطار اليوم
لنشاهد اذا كان هنالك اي تغيير حتى
الرحلات لم يتم الغاء الرحلات لم يتم
التوقف القطارات توقفت فقط في فتره
الاعلان عن الغاره الجويه اللي هي فتره
الاعلان وبعد ذلك عندما
تم الغاء حاله الانذار الجوي مباشره
القطارات في التحرك مباشره حركه المواصلات
بشكل طبيعي كذلك مترو الانفاق يعمل بشكل
طبيعي كل شيء كما كان في السابق لم يتغير
شيء تماما هل وزاره الدفاع اليوم تحدثت عن
اي تصعيد على الجبهات خاصه بعد هذا
الاستهداف للكرملين
صحيح يعني دعيني ابدا بالامين العام لمجلس
الامن والدفاع الاوكراني ادانيلف والذي
تحدث عن ضخموت تحديدا ربط هذا ايضا بهذا
التصعيد من قبل موسكو وقال ان الكريم غير
قادر على السيطره على مخموت ولذلك يحاول
ان تكون هنالك دعايه لاستخدامها في الداخل
الروسي ايضا قال انهم يضعون في التقويم
يعني كل مره تاريخ جديد لانهاء العمليات
في ضخموت الان
التقويم الجديد هو هو التاسع من مايو عيد
النصر الروسي وهذا ايضا سيفشل كما وضعوا
في السابق كما قال في عيد ميلاد الرئيس
بوتين ايضا كانوا قد وضعوا هذا التاريخ
لانهاء العمليات في مخموت وهم فشلوا في
ذلك والان وضعوا هذا التاريخ الجديد
التاسع من مايو وسيفشلون في ذلك الوضع
مستقر تماما ايضا كان هنالك اجتماع اليوم
للقاده العسكريين او بما يسمى يعني مجلس
الحرب وهو فيه كل القاده وكان
جهاز المخابرات جهاز الامن الوطني القائد
القوات البريه القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه كذلك وزير الدفاع
اجتمعوا اليوم
وناقشوا الوضع في الجبهه يعني بالخصوص في
مخمود بؤره الاعمال العسكريه والنشطه
اليوم هي بخموت مارينكا افديفيكا ولكن
الوضع كما ككل يوم هنالك هجمات من قبل
القوات الروسيه تم صد واحد واربعين هجوما
من قبل قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه في هذه
الجبهات الثلاث تعلمين ان هنالك استهداف
تم لمدينه خرسون هنالك ثمانيه عشره قتيلا
وعدد من الجرحى حول 22 جريحا في خرسون
ايضا اعلن عمده اخرسون عن حظر للتجوال
يبدا في الخامس مما هنالك طبعا يعني
خطا بسيط تقع فيه معظم الوسائل الاعلام
كما تابعت في حول العالم ان الحضره
التجوال يبدا من اليوم حظر التجوال يبدا
من الخامس مما ماي وينتهي في الثامن من
مايو يبدا في الثامنه مساء في الخامس من
مايو وينتهي في السادسه صباحا صباح الثامن
من مايو اعطيت مهله للمواطنين لقضاء
حوائجهم لشراء الطعام والاحتياجات
الضروريه من دواء وغيرها وبعد ذلك سيبدا
هذا الحظر لمده ثلاثه ايام في مدينه خرسون
وعلل ذلك طبعا العمده بانه سيكون هنالك
انتشار للاجهزه الامنيه وهنالك عمليات سوف
تتم وحتى تامين المنطقه بشكل تام لذلك
يرجو من المواطنين الالتزام بهذا الحظر
وطبعا دائما هذا الحظر هنالك عواقب
قانونيه لمن يخرق مثل هذا الحظر ويخرج الى
الشوارع في الوقت المحدد اشكرك حذيفه عدل
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل دائما
سنكون معك في حال اي تطور
اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدراليه الروسي احباط
انشطه شبكه تابعه للمخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه كانت تخطط لتنفيذه هجمه
ارهابيه في شبه جزيره القرم كما اكد
الجهاز في بيان ان المتفجرات التي تمت
مصادرتها من المعتقلين اثناء التحضير
لهجمات ارهابيه في القرن تتطابق مع تلك
المستخدمه في تفجير خطوط السكك الحديديه
في الثالث والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
جزيره القرم رسخت قوه موسكو العسكريه في
البحر الاسود لسنوات وشكلت خط امداد
لعمليتها الخاصه في اوكرانيا مكاسب جوهريه
باتت مهدده مع تزايد الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه هناك في هذا الاطار شددت موسكو
رقبتها لتفكك مؤخرا شبكه اوكرانيا زعمت
انها تخطط لهجمات تخريبيه وارهابيه في
القرن
ستبقى روسيه للابد تعهد قطعه عام 2014 عند
ضم شبه جزيره القرم وانتزاعها من الخريطه
الاوكرانيه غير ان انفجارات وغارات جويه
عده اظهرت وفق اعلام غربيه هشاشه الوجود
الروسي هناك كما ابرزت شبه الجزيره كجزء
من اهداف اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب للتغلب
على الرعب من الضروري ان ننتصر في المعركه
ضد العدوان الروسي وان نحرر القرم
الضربات الاوكرانيه في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم ومن ضمنها استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبل هدفها
استنزاف اللوجيات ومراكز القياده والسيطره
اي تعطيل خطوط الامداد الروسيه اولا كما
تهدف لعرقله توغل موسكو جنوبي اوكرانيا
ومخططها البرمائي للاندفاع غربا باتجاه
اوداسا وانشاء جسر بري الى مولدوفا الا ان
الضربه الكبرى تمثلت بالانفجار الذي هز
جسر الحيوي في اكتوبر 2022 ما ادى لتدمير
جزء منه وتعطيل حركه النقل وان لفتره هذا
الجسر هو الاطول في اوروبا ويمتد لتسعه
عشر كيلو مترا بلغت تكلفه التشييده ثلاثه
مليارات و600 مليون دولار ويعد حلقه وصل
بين شبه جزيره القرم ومنطقه كرسنو دارك
راي الروسيه شمالي القوقاز نائب رئيس مجلس
الدومه الروسي وص انها الانفجار بمثابه
اعلان حربه في معدته الخارجيه الروسيه
دليلا على ما وصفته الطبيعه الارهابيه
للحكومه الاوكرانيه اما مستشار زيلنسكي
فاكد ان الانفجار مجرد بدايه طالما ان كل
شيء غير شرعي يجب تدميره وفق تعبيره
الضربات الاوكرانيه في شبه الجزيره جاءت
متقطعه على مدى اشهر الا ان وثيرتها
ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال الايام الاخيره وهي
وفق الوصف الروسيه تعتبر اعمالا ارهابيه
وتخريبيه يسعى لتفكيك شبكه منفذها
في اخر تطورات الميدانيه التي تشهدها
الحرب في اوكرانيا اكد مراسل العربيه بان
قوات فاجنر الروسيه قدمت في عمق المحور
الغربي من مدينه باخمت وسيطرت على مساحات
اضافيه واشار الى ان المعارك اشتدت حول
الطريق السريع في بلده رومادا شمال غرب
المدينه وكريسنايا في نفس المحور كما وسع
الجيش الروسي من تطويقه لمدينه بعد عمليات
عسكريه عنيفه واشار الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما مضاده على الجيش
الروسي في مناطق القتال غرب مدينه مارينكا
في المقابل اعلنت السلطات والمحليه
الاوكرانيه فرض حضري تجول في خرسون
الواقعه قرب خط المواجهه اعتبارا من مساء
الجمعه ولمده 58 ساعه واوضح رئيس الاداره
العسكريه المحليه او الكسند
على تيليجرام انه خلال حظر التجول سيمنع
التنقل في شوارع المدينه
نذكر مره اخرى بالكرملين وهو الحسن الروسي
المنيع في قلب موسكو والذي يحظى بحمايه
كبيره من القوات الروسيه نتابع التفاصيل
في التقرير التالي
رئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم بطائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت موسكو
الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي تحمي مركز
المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل المدن
التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على كريملين خاص
بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي تابعنا لقطات له
هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين الذي يطل على
الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره تابعه لرئاسه
الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر عن القصر
الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار وكما اعلنت
موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير الطائرتين
المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات الالكترونيه في
الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غرب الكرملين
عبر زوما ينضم اليه من دبي الباحث في شؤون
الامنيات قهوه دكتور قهوه اهلا بك معنا
كيف يمكن ان تطال او تصل مسيره الى
الكرملين وهو الاكثر تشديد امني عليه
طبعا مسيرات معروف بصعوبه رصدها يعني هذه
المعضله التي تواجهها جيوش عده رغم
امتلاكها اليوم
لمنظومات رادار متقدمه متخصصه برصد
اجسام صغيره نسبيا
الا ان هذه المسيرات خاصه ان كانت تقاد من
جانب طيار ماهر يبقيها على ارتفاع منخفض
يستطيع ان يحدد مسار يخطط له يكون بعيد عن
شبكات رادار عن مناطق غير سكنيه يمكنه من
التورغل في عمق ارض العدو
اوكرانيا
دكتور رياض يعني نحن نريد منك ان نفهم هل
من الممكن ان تكون اتت من اوكرانيا هذه
المسيرات الى قلب العاصمه
هناك احتمالان اليوم الاول ان تكون اتت عن
طريق اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تملك
مسيرات من ايام الاتحاد السوفياتي
وهي اليوجي
اللي قامت بتطويرها وتحديثها لتمكينها من
تنفيذ عمليات اليوم
وشهدنا مسبقا انها استخدمت ضد اهداف في
مطارات في جنوب روسيا
هلا هل تمكنت اليوم من زياده مدى هذه
المسيرات لتصل عمر موسكو تكنولوجيا هذا
ممكن وقد تكون نشهد اليوم اول عمليه في
هذه المسافه البعيده في العمق الروسي وان
تحقق ذلك فهذا يعني نذير سيء لانه
ينقل اليوم اجواء هذه الحرب الى عمق
الاراضي الروسيه التي حتى
الان تنعم بمستوى عال من البندوق وكان
هناك جزء كبير من الشعب الروسي لا يشعر
باثار الحرب بشكلها المباشر يعني برايك
ستغير روسيا الان من مقوله
انها هذه معركه الى حرب
يسعى بوتين
لاستخدمها لمكاسب سياسيه داخليه فقط لا
اكثر انما الواقع نحن في حاله حرب بامتياز
بين دولتين هلا هناك طرف اخر يقول انها قد
تقوم من عمل داخلي عمل داخلي اما يكون عن
طريق شهاده اجهزه استخباراتيه تابعه
لاوكرانيا او قد تكون ضمن صراع المحاور في
النظام الروسي حتى الان من الصعب معرفه
ذلك حتى الان بمعرفه ذلك دكتور قهوجي ولكن
على المدى الاطول هل من الممكن معرفه
الحقيقه بهكذا استهداف
طبعا يعني مع الوقت مستقبلا قد تنكشف
الامور
وتعرف مصدر هذه الطائره انما يعني الشيء
الصعب اليوم ان روسيا تمتلك ايضا نفس
انواع هذه الطائرات التي تملكها اوكرانيا
لتعود في حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي انما
هل تمكنت اوكرانيا فعلا من تحديثها
وتطويرها وزياده مداها هذا سيظهر مستقبلا
اوكرانيا تشن عمليات متعدده خلف الخطوط
داخل الاراضي الروسيه انما تلقيها في اطار
العمل العسكري الاستخبارات السري السري هي
لا تعلن عن هذه العمليات لا تعترف فيها
رغم اعلان الروسي عن حدوثها مثل
الحوادث التي تعرضت لها القطارات مؤخرا في
البلدات الروسيه المح
لاوكرانيا
مهاجمه او تفجيرات في بعض المنشات النقديه
هذه عمليات
جرت في اراضي روسيه انما لم تعترف
اوكرانيا في هذه العمليات اوكرانيا تحاول
ان تعترف فقط ان هناك حرب دفاعيه تجري على
اراضيها فقط هذه الحرب الان ستنتقل الى
مرحله اخرى دكتور رياض ما الذي سيتغير بعد
استهداف الكرملين يعني هناك هيبه لروسيا
اهتزت اليوم البعض يعتبر بان هذا من من
اخطر التطورات الحاصله منذ اليوم الاول
لهذه الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
طبعا يعني الوصول هذه المسيرات لعمق روسيا
وللعاصمه والكرملين بالذات طبعا مؤشر ليس
بالسهل
انما يعني ماذا قد تفعله
روسيا هل ستجتاح اوكرانيا هي تجتاح
اوكرانيا اصلا هل ستقوم بقصف استراتيجي
على مدن اوكرانيه هي تقوم بذلك تقريبا كل
يوم قامت قبل يومين بقصف صاروخي استخدمت
فيه صواريخ فرض صوتيه ومتنوعه على اهداف
عديده ماذا يمكن ان تقوم
يطلب بقتل حكومه زيلينس كقتل زيلينسكي
واعضاء حكومته هي حاولت من اول يوم الهجوم
العام الماضي كان اول هدف هو
وفشلت في ذلك كان هناك انزال قوات خاصه في
كييف تستهدف كشخصيه وبالتالي ليس هناك اي
شيء لم تقم به روسيا حتى اليوم عسكريا ضد
اوكرانيا
باستثناء استخدام السلاح النووي يعني جميع
الاسلحه استخدمت لم يبقى اي نوع من
الاسلحه في الترسانه الروسيه لم يستخدم ضد
اوكرانيا حتى اليوم بعد هذا الاستهداف
السلاح النووي سيبقى مستبعدا وخاصه بانها
لوحت فيه منذ اليوم الاول لهذه المعارك
ليس من الواضح ان كان ستلجا الى هذا الامر
يعني استخدام السلاح الناوي دونه عقابات
وعواقب كبيره بالنسبه لروسيا لانها ستفتح
على نفسها
جبهه اوسع من جانب الناتو والدول في شرق
اوروبا وبالتالي يعني هو ليس بخيار امثل
لانه
سيعرض روسيا لسيناريوات لا تريدها في هذه
المرحله وايضا يعني
الضربات
الاوكرانيه ضد روسيا كانت موجعه اكثر يعني
في خسارتها لاراضي شاسعه
عليها في اوكرانيا اليوم
هناك تحضير اوكراني لهجوم واسع مضاد هناك
تحضير قد بدا الاستهداف اليومي مؤخرا لطرق
الخطوط المواصل
الروسيه لعده جبهات وتحديدا في الجبهه
الجنوبيه هو مؤشر ان هناك تحضير لعمل
لعمليه اجتياح لاستعاده اراضي في مناطق
زابوريتشيا ومنطقه خرسون الاعلان عن منع
التجول في خرسون ايضا مؤشر عن التحضير
لعمل عسكري مع هذا يحدث عاده عندما هناك
يكون في تحركات عسكريه كثيفه
تحاول
تسعى اوكرانيا لمنع تحرك اي جواسيس لروسيا
وبالتالي تقوم بفرض منع التجول
لاطفاء
تعتيم على تحركاتها العسكريه
وبالتالي هناك اليوم ترقب لهجوم ما
قد تستخدم روسيا هذه العمليه
الهجوم على الكريم لينك كح
ضربات استراتيجيه كبيره لاستهداف
المركز القياده يعني القصر الرئاسه في
اوكرانيا مراكز وجود
وقياداته
يعني هناك مجموعه من الخيارات قد
تلجا اليها القياده الروسيه كرد على ما
جرى في موسكو انما حتى الان لا تاكيد من
اي جهه خارجيه عن ان هذا الهجوم كان
بالفعل مصدره اوكرانيا
لك من دبي كنت معي عبر زوما الباحث في
شؤون الامن والدفاع دكتور رياض قهوجي شكرا
وفق البيانات الصادره عن الكريم مرت 16
دقيقه بين هجمتي طائرتين المسيرتين على
مقر اقامه الرئيس بلاديمير بوتين حيث وجهت
موسكو الاتهام متوعده اياها بالرد في
الزمان والمكان المناسبين
في الساعه الثانيه 27 دقيقه صباحا بتوقيت
موسكو هجوم الطائره المسايره الاولى
انفجرت فوق قصر مجلس الشيوخ متسببه
باندلاع حريق على سطحه في الساعه الثانيه
وثلاث واربعين دقيقه هجوم الطائره
المسايره الثانيه سقط حطامها على اراضي
قصر الكرملين المسيرتان من نوع يوجي 22
صينيه الصنع
بعد الهجوم على الكرملين موسكو تمنع طيران
المسيرات في سماء العاصمه
بمحاوله اغتيال فلاديمير بوتين مشيرا الى
انه لم يصاب باي اذى جراء الهجوم اوكرانيا
قالت ان لا علاقه لها بالهجوم وان اتهامات
روسيا مقدمه لعمل عسكري روسي شامل
الكريملين قال انه يحتفظ بحق الرد في
المكان والزمان المناسبين مجلس الدوما
يدعو لتدمير نظام
قال ان واشنطن تنظر بالربا لكل ما يصدر عن
الكرملين
الامم المتحده قالت انه لا يمكن تاكيد
المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني على
الكرملين
كيف ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا محمد
اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو الوضع لديك الان
يعني حاله ترقب تسود العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف ومعظم المدن الاوكرانيه خاصه بعد
يعني الاعلان عن حظر تجول في مدينه خرسون
لمده
ما يعني ان هناك تحرك انه ربما سيكون هناك
تحرك عسكري في مدينه خرصون خاصه بعدما
تعرضت هذه المدينه لضربات صاروخيه اليوم
حصيله القتلى 19 قتيلا و51 جريحا حتى هذه
اللحظه بعد استهداف طالما محطه القطارات
ومحل تجاريه وابنيه سكنيه داخل مدينه
خرسون ايضا مدينه زفروجيا تعرضت لسقوط
صواريخ اس 300 مقاطعه بنيبر ايضا تعرضت
لقاسه مدفعي وسقوط صواريخ اس 3 وهناك
معلومات عن سقوط قتيل واربعه جراحه بعد
استهداف احد المنازل السكنيه مدينه خالكم
او مقاطعه خالكم ايضا تساقطت قذائف تم
اطلاقها من مقاطعه عند اطراف مقاطعه
لوغانسك ومقاطعه سقطت على يعني احراج
ومناطق سكنيه او قرى سكنيه في تلك
المقاطعه العاصمه هناك هدوء حازر كما ذكرت
الجميع يتركب هناك ما يتداول في الراي
العام الاوكراني انه ربما سيكون هناك
ضربات صاروخيه الليله او خلال اليومين
المقبلين خاصه ليلا تقوم روسيا بضربات
صاروخيه خلال الفتره الاخيره على غرار ما
حصل يوم الجمعه عندما كان هناك ضربات
صاروخيه استهدفت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
ومحيطها بعد اصاب احد الصواريخ الذي سقط
على مبنى سكن مما ادى الى سقوط عدد كبير
من القتلى 27 قتيلا هناك دعوات من السلطات
الاوكرانيه للجميع بالالتزام بالانذار
الجوي وعندما خاصه ليلا عندما يكون هناك
انذار جوي يطلب من المواطنين الدخول الى
الملاجئ وعدم الاستهتار بهذا الانذار
الجوي منعا لسقوط عدد كبير من الضحايا
خاصه انه ربما ستكون لذه الفعل او القصف
هذه المره سيكون عنيف على المدن
الاوكرانيه وقد يطال مباني سكنيه ومنشات
مدنيه لذلك
وخاصه بالاجراءات الامنيه بعدما حصل اليوم
في الكرملين
حتى هذه اللحظه الاجواء عاديه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف حركه المرور عاديه المحل
التجاريه كانت تعمل بشكل طبيعي ولكن تقفل
عند دوي سفارات الانذار ولكن بعد انتهاء
سفارات الانذار عند الساعه السادسه مساء
عادت الحياه الى طبيعه الى طبيعتها ولكن
نرى يعني ردود فعل المدنيين والمواطنين
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الجميع يعني
مترقب لما سيحدث هناك حديث انه ربما
ويتداول عبر شبكه تيليجرام انه ربما روسيا
والتلجا الى استخدام اسلحه تكتيكيه او
صواريخ من نوع فنجان لضرب مراكز اساسيه في
وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ولكن هذا يبقى
تكهنات ومعلومات وتخوف وترقب من الشارع
الاوكراني يعني معظم الاراء يعني ردود
الفعل السياسيه الاوكرانيه اليوم جاءت
برفض ونفي تام لمسؤوليه اوكرانيا حول
استهداف الكريم او اطلاق مسيرتين باتجاه
الرئيس الاوكراني قال يعني ان الدنيا
تقاتل الجيش الاوكراني واوكرانيا تقاتل
للدفاع عن اراضيها وتقاتل داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه
في تصريح عبر تيليجرام قال ان لا علاقه
لاوكرانيا لا من قريب ولا من بعيد بالهجوم
او بالحدث الذي
بعد المواقف الاوكرانيه تجاه ما حدث اليوم
في موسكو ولكن دعني الان اذهب الى موسكو
مع الباحثه في العلاقات الدوليه في مدرسه
الاقتصاد العليا لانا بادفان لانا اهلا بك
معنا كيف يمكن تقييم ما حصل اليوم خاصه
بانه تم استهداف الكرملين برمزيته
بمركزه وايضا بموقعه الجغرافي قلب العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
يعني بالتاكيد هذا استفزاز كبير من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني وتصعيد خطير ولا سيما ان
هذه المره الطائرات دون الطيار ضربت عقبه
ومكان القرار الصنع القرار السياسي الروسي
بالتالي هذه الرساله واضحه للجانب الروسي
بان اوكرانيا اصبحت الان دوله لا يمكن
التساهم معها او الاستهانه بها سابقا كان
هناك مقترحات لعقد مفاوضات بين الجانب
الروسي ومع الرئيس
بان نواب مجلس ادومه يرفضون يرفضون رفضا
تاما في محاوله اعاده ملف الاوكراني في
دائره المفاوضات والنقاش وخاصه مع الرئيس
ايليننسكي بالتالي الامور اصبحت لا عوده
لا يمكن اليوم ان نتحدث عن مفاوضات السلام
او حوار مع الجانب الاوكراني هناك استفزاز
كبير وتصعيد خطير هناك مطالب روسيه سياسيه
تطالب بان يكون هناك عمليه على كافه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وان لا تقتصر فقط على
العمليه الع سكريه في هل هذا من الممكن ان
يحصل يعني هل ستفتح معركه مفتوحه موسكو
الان
هناك ضبابيه كبيره في التصريحات
من قبل الكريم حقيقه بالتالي نحن نستمع
دائما الى التصريحات التي تصدر من بيتكوف
تصريحات تفضل مجلس الدوما بالتالي اليوم
الداخل الروسي ينتظر الرد الحقيقي من كيف
سترد روسي هذه المره لدى عسكري امرت سياسي
ولكن يمكن ان نتوصل الى نتيجه واحده وهي
تصريح الذي قالت به قالت له به الزخرفه
لان روسيا سوف ترد بشكل انتقامي بالتالي
نحن على بعض ساعات من ربما تصعيد عسكريا
روسي
البعض يعتبر يعني كان معي دبلوماسي
اوكرانيا
وكانت اجابته انه بعد استهداف الكرملين
وقلب العاصمه موسكو لن نسمع باي اقاله باي
استقاله يعني هنا صغر امنيه كبيره
طبعا بعض الخبراء العسكريين قد فسروا هذا
الامر هذه بان من يترصد الطائرات دون
الطيار كان يريد ان يعرف الى مدى يمكن ان
تطير هذه الطائره وما المكان المستهدف ومن
ثم عندما اخترقت جدار الكريم تم اسقاطها
وتعطيل
الضبط لدى هذه الطائره بالتالي هناك وجهات
نظر وخاصه فيما يتعلق بان الكريم في يعني
في المنطقه ذاتها هل هناك دفاعات جويه
وانظمه يعني متطوره وايضا هناك وفق
الخبراء العسكريين الروس حمايه يعني عن
طريق الجو دون اي تحال دون اي اختراق سواء
كانت بالصواريخ او حتى طائرات دون طيار
بالتالي هناك يعني العديد من الاجوبه ولا
يوجد الى حد هذه اللحظه ايضا هناك نظريه
اخرى تقول بان من الممكن ان روسيا ان تكون
قامت بهذا العمل يعني اوكرانيا تقول بانه
هذه هذا فيلم هذا
عمليه تعتبرها بانها من صنع روسيا من اجل
من اجل العيد النصر الذي سيقام في التاسع
من مايو بانه لن يكون هناك مثلا حشد كبير
ولان الناس ترفض هذه الحرب التي تقوم بها
روسيا على اوكرانيا ولا يريدون ان
يؤثر ذلك على الارض فقامت بهذا العمل من
اجل حشد الشعبيه من جديد الى جانب الرئيس
بوتين
يمكن القيام بشتى انواع العمليات ولكن دون
استهداف مكان الصنع القرار الرئاسي الروسي
يعني هذا الاستهداف اليوم هو غير منطقي
ولا يمكن ان يتقبله المواطن الروسي اليوم
بان يشعر بان كان هناك طائره دون الطيار
على مقربه من رئيس الدوله وكان هناك عمل
ارهابي يطال استهداف هذا الرئيس بالتالي
لا يمكن ان نتوقع ان هناك سيناريو
بروباجاندا روسيا تعمل على هذا صنع هذا
الفيلم لانه هذه النظريه هي خطيره جدا لو
فيما تحدثنا بها ثانيا ديسكوف قال ان في
تسعه ما سيكون هناك احتفالات كالمعتاد
سيكون هناك يعني احتفال عسكري كبير
بالالات وبالتالي لم يتغير اي شيء بالتالي
من يقول بان بان روسيا قد حاولت صنع هذا
الفيلم والبروبغندا من اجل اضعاف احتفال
بهذا اليوم او من اجل تقليب
غضب كبير ليس مع الجانب الحكومي انما غضب
مما حصل من اختراق من قبل المسيرات وثانيا
ان يكون هناك رد حقيقي الى حد هذه اللحظه
لم نسمع رد حقيقي وما سوف تؤول اليه
الاوضاع وما الجواب الحق الذي يمكن ان
يشفي غل الداخل الروسي بما ستقوم به روسيا
في الساعات القادمه او في الايام القادمه
لان هذا الموضوع لم يد
هذا الامر يتعلق بالامن القومي الروسي
لانا من المعروف بان اوكرانيا لديها حلفاء
وحلفاء اقوياء لديك الولايات المتحده
الدول الاوروبيه حلف الناتو الى اي مدى من
الممكن ان تكون حدود
هذا التصعيد وخاصه بحال توسعت العمليات
العسكريه وانتقلت
الامور الى حرب مفتوحه هل سيكون هناك حدود
لروسيا ستبقى تبقي عليها خاصه يعني حتى لا
تستفز ايضا الولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه
يعني لا يمكن الان ان نتحدث عن هذا
السيناريو لانه ايضا تصعيد خطير فيما
يتعلق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اليوم مثلا الجانب الروسي
ينتظر التوضيح الامريكي هل ربما سياسه
الامريكيه سوف تضغط على اوكرانيا الا
تتجاوز المعركه بينها وبين الجانب الروسي
اي لا تخترق الاراضي الروسيه وخاصه
العاصمه الروسيه ولكن حتى هذا الاحتمال هو
ضعيف لان يتم يعني اليوم تم استهداف عكر
القرار والصناع السياده الروسي بالتالي لا
يمكن ان نتنبا باستمرار الحقيقه سواء كان
لروسيا او حتى حلفاء روسيا فيما يتعلق
بالساعات القادمه وما اراد الحقيقه الكريم
شكرا لك من موسكو الباحثه في العلاقات
الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد العليا لانا
ساعود مجددا الى محمد بابا الصحفيه من كاز
محمد بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا هل تنس مع حلفائها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحلف الناتو بخصوص اي
تصعيد محتمل الان من روسيا هل هناك
اتصالات حاليا بين الجانبين
يعني بعد بعد تسريب وثائق من
الفينتاجون يعني اصبح هناك سياسه جديده
لدى الجانب الاوكراني في وضع العمليات
العسكريه هناك تم تصغير الحلقه المتصله
باداره القرار الاوكرانيه عاده الجانب
الاوكراني والقياده العسكريه للجيش
الاوكراني تتشاور مع الحلفاء حول طبيعه
العمليات وخاصه ان اوكرانيا تحصل على دعم
استخباراتي واسع من يعني اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه التي تساعد اوكرانيا
استخباراتيا في تحديد الاهداف خاصه عبر
صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي تزود بها
معظم الدول الغربيه اوكرانيا حول المواقع
العسكريه ولكن القرار باتخاذ اي عمل عسكري
هو يعود لهيئه اركان العامه الاوكرانيه
بالتنسيق مع الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وعاده
ويعني اكثر من مسؤول اوكرانيا صرح انه
خاصه يعني
مجلس الامن والدفاع او سكرتير الامن
والدفاع الاوكراني قال ان مثلا عن الحديث
عن الهجوم المضاد هناك فقط خمسه اشخاص
يعلمون تفاصيل وموعد هذا الهجوم المضاد
وكيفيه وكيفيه يعني تنفيذ هذا الهجوم
المضاد لذلك تم تغيير استراتيجيه العمل
داخل داخل وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وهيئه
الاركان العامه وحتى الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
عاده اوكرانيا هي صرح اكثر من مره رئيس
الاوكراني ان الجيش الاوكراني والرئيس
الاوكراني هم من يتخذون القرار حول نوعيه
العمليات وكيفيه تنفيذ العمليات وموعدها
ولكن دائما هناك استشارات غربيه يعني تكون
بها اوكرانيا خاصه ان اوكرانيا الان تصلح
عبر شركاء غربيين وكان هناك خطوط حمر من
الدول الغربيه حول استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه بالاسلحه التي يتم
تقديمها والتزمت اوكرانيا بهذا التحذير
ومعظم ما يعني ما تقوم به اوكرانيا هي
باسلحه تمتلكها اوكرانيا من الحقبه
السوفيت يه او اسلحه من صناعه اوكرانيا
شكرا لك من كافه الصحفي محمد البابا
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الساعه
الاخباريه ولكن التغطيه مستمره مع الزميل
طاهر بركي التقيكم بعد ساعه من الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات